[Music]
the european union is serious about our
commitment to fight the climate crisis
by 2030 we aim to cut greenhouse gas
emissions by at least 55 percent this is
a key component of the european green
deal
to reach climate neutrality by 2050
restore biodiversity and advance towards
zero pollution for water air and soil we
need to take action in every sector of
the economy
a climate neutral future can bring
prosperity and a safe and healthy
environment for everyone
by applying the latest science we can
develop the necessary innovative ideas
in time
in the sevilla process the eu is working
together with industry and ngos to
reduce pollution from over 52 000 large
industrial plants in europe
the sevilla process helps to take
decisions based on consensus and
transparency underpinned by solid
scientific and technical data
[Music]
commission through its joint research
center has years of experience
identifying the right technologies for
sustainable progress we connect
scientists ngos and industry with
european and national authorities to
reduce pollution and guarantee a
globally competitive industry this is
our way the european way
the civilian process is a genuine
european achievement it is a tested
reliable mechanism it uses science to
forge agreements for a healthier
environment and more competitive
industry
let's use this experience to drive the
green transition forward
we must now apply our best ideas and get
ready for a green and healthy future
[Music]